[Musique]
alors tu vis au 28 barbery lane depuis
combien de temps j'ai emménagé ici en
1966 il y a plus de 50 ans et j'imagine
que c'était bien différent
par certains aspects
[Musique]
dites moi que j'ai fumé trop d'herbe
parce que là je vois pas d'autre
explication
je pensais vraiment pas qu'un jour
marianne si bolton se décidera revenir à
bordeaux il est plus qu un simple
appartement de toute évidence c'est là
qu'on est devenu ce qu'on est
ce bar a sauvé ma [ __ ]
[Musique]
ça normal de se sentir mal ta mère que
t'as pas vu depuis des années vient de
débarquer sans prévenir
quoi de neuf
elle est persuadée que je suis sa mère
biologique biologique
[Musique]
ap
une fois que tu t'es senti réellement
compris par quelqu'un comme un as
madrigal peu de comprendre
t'as pas envie de partir je ne saurais
pas décrire ce que ça exactement tout ce
que je suis et tout ce qui me représente
vient de barbery lane shauna a le droit
de connaître la vérité
il arrive parfois que la vérité soit un
fardeau qu'il faut pas personne
[Musique]
chaque fois que je la regarde tout ce
que je vois c'est que j'étais pas s'il
pourra t il est plutôt évident que tu es
le centre de ce petit univers
[Musique]
je les appelle mes enfants à ce qu'il le
sera
[Musique]
ah ouais bon